[Musik]
die kleine valeria leidet unter einem
extrem seltenen gendefekt sie kann sich
nicht bewegen und hat täglich unzählige
epileptische anfälle eine behandlung
gibt es nicht
ihre eltern haben in einer weltweiten
recherche ein team von wissenschaftlern
gefunden die ein medikament für die
anderthalbjährige entwickeln wollen das
kostet aber zwei millionen franken mit
einer groß angelegten spendenaktion
versuchen sie das geld aufzutreiben
normalerweise sterben diese kinder früh
darum ist es ein wettlauf gegen die zeit
[Musik]
valeria ist das erste kind von mario und
alexandra schenkel kurz nach ihrer
geburt haben sie gemerkt dass etwas
nicht stimmt
die den wirkstoff ethische euro gesteckt
dass sich die sich
mit grösster stehen bis jetzt mit ihrem
spital oder ablegen wie etwas denn das
mit sich bringt das ganze deshalb
militär einen abschätzen
es dauerte wochen bis die ärzte die
ursache fanden das ergebnis valeria
leidet an einer mutation auf dem kcn t1
gehen die nervenzellen in ihrem gehirn
arbeiten nicht richtig zusammen deshalb
ist ihre motorische und kognitive
entwicklung stark beeinträchtigt
weltweit gibt es nicht einmal 100 kinder
die an dieser form des gendefekts leiden
rosi dass sie selber stufe ist die
andere schien
ziemlich fehlern zu markus und
und wird beatmet sind die ganze zeit im
spital und so wirklich im hohlen zahn
lange wenn ich das 14
profis ihre gold oder und seine haut
einfach schwerstbehinderten
dass das dass das war nicht viel ich so
das ist sicher so nicht
machen
mai 2009 10 als erstes müssen die eltern
das geld auftreiben an ihrem wohnort bei
luzern starten sie heute eine sammel
kampagne eine million kommt aus ihrem
ersparten von verwandten und freunden
doch für die zweite million brauchen sie
hilfe
der startschuss ist ein benefizkonzert
ich hoffe dass mich mit ihr hund du sie
krank oder so lange betreiben da geht es
um die balance aktionen
des staates und so ist das nicht eine
pfütze wo es hilfe genommen ich alle
zeiten sind so 14 gruppe 14 stand oder
als dem erst kürzlich
das ist
grossartig ein video seiner unterstützer
einer ihrer freunde hat die luzerner
band da der ante portas angefragt ob sie
bereit wären ein konzert zugunsten von
valeria zu geben
[Musik]
man kann doch immer wieder über diese
benefiz aufrücken wird und das hat es
auf alle gerührt und das ist richtig so
denn wenn sie es berührt
krimis und der war aber weil mir das
stück
das konzert stößt auf großes interesse
die 250 eintritte waren sofort weg
jeder gibt so viel er will oder kann
sie sammeln aber nicht nur hier am
konzert sie konnten die medien dazu
bringen breit über valeria zu berichten
auf einer crowdfunding seite sind so in
den ersten 24 stunden schon über 300000
franken zusammengekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
danke
und mir hoffe ganz fest dass sie sich
dann aber ich persönlich bedanken kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
während des konzerts kümmern sich die
organisatoren im hintergrund um die
spendenkasse
und dann ist es wirklich aus dem auto
geklaut wurde und jetzt haben besucher
wandeln dass wir das geld weg bringen
denn es ist einiges zusammengekommen
[Applaus]
alexandra bringt das geld noch in der
nacht zur bank
am konzert sammeln sie fast 13.000
franken ein stolzer betrag und ein guter
anfang aber bis zur million ist es noch
ein weiter weg
die sammelaktion geht am wochenende
weiter 50 freiwillige darunter auch
valeri us großeltern bauen zwischen
luzern und zürich stände auf doch ist es
nicht unangenehm fremde menschen um geld
zu bitten das blut wird das
überschreiten der schwelle und wenn wir
haben den gesamtkontext glaube ich denn
da das gestein das kommt wieder eine
taktische sind
das thema sowie motive des gemeinsames
ziel
wo sich
zu engagieren
maria schenkel ist rechtsanwalt mit
eigener kanzlei in luzern
die spenden sommer ist über nacht auf
über 420.000 franken gestiegen
es ist bis heute europaweit das
erfolgreichste crowdfunding im bereich
medizin
ich meine eigene
geld meines megacool bessere keine mache
doch wieso müssen die eltern die
entwicklung des medikaments überhaupt
selber bezahlen wären dafür nicht die
krankenkasse oder die iv zuständig
dieses
medikament vor dem haare wirkt nicht
finanziert werden von der iv noch wurde
von der krankenkasse und die schweiz ist
leider so dass weder eva franke
entwickelte stück und meine medikamente
zahlen kommt dazu dass die
wissenschaftler der harvard medical
school in amerika nicht versprechen
können ob und wie das medikament werden
wird die hoffnungen sind aber groß sie
dankt dass sie sich kampfstark und dass
sie sicher entwickeln bis hin zu sie
wird ganz
normaler mensch oder ganz ein gesunder
mensch oder aber davor krampf und sich
entwickeln bis jetzt so ganz normal ist
natürlich eine große spannung dem
landtag bis so ein dass ich runter
gerade die epileptischen krampfanfälle
quellen valeria 30 40 mal am tag
[Applaus]
gegen die krämpfe hilft cdu es lindert
die symptome
das medikament soll die grunderkrankung
heilen dass ärzte und forscher team in
den usa ist überzeugt dass es helfen
wird bei einem anderen kind mit einem
ähnlichen gen defekt hat es funktioniert
voller hoffnung fliegt maria schenkel am
nächsten tag nach holland er hat ihn
leiden ein labor gefunden dass die
ersten prototypen von valeria das
medikament testet
[Musik]
ich habe euch etwas mitgebracht das ist
für dich und dein team es ist schwer wir
haben es selber gemacht
danke
vielen dank für alles was ihr für
valeria macht und für eure hilfe
maria schenkel ist zwar kein arzt hat
inzwischen aber sehr viel gelernt über
diesen äußerst seltenen gendefekt und
die mögliche behandlung
das prinzip so genannte oligo binden
sich an das defekte gehen und schalten
es aus
so könnte die reizübertragung in
valerius gehirn wieder mehr oder weniger
normal funktionieren
was noch im anschluss zu schnell stärken
ziehen oder zum zum ziel wo es schon
kompliziert meine kkh nicht ob es die
sind
und welche nicht und so die nächste
zeichnung ist frustrierend der zeitplan
jetzt sind wir hier dann kommen zwei
weitere runden
und kassiert dafür dass sie und ich
versuche immer wieder bis zu das manu
besser machen sich alles gut machen zu
viel gut die teile oder
und
die besten dieser teile aus amerika
lässt mario im labor untersuchen die
firma ist spezialisiert auf solche tests
die groß schätzt der wissenschaftler die
chance ein dass sie wirklich ein
passendes logo finden werden
[Musik]
es ist sehr schwierig vorauszusagen ob
wir etwas finden werden das valeria
hilft ich glaube wir werden etwas finden
dass das mutierte gen von valeria
verändern kann
aber ich weiß nicht ob wir so weit
verändern können dass es eine wirkung
hat
aber es gibt keine alternative
die einzige chance erhält
im moment kumulieren sich seine probleme
alles braucht mehr zeit und kostet viel
mehr geld als ursprünglich geplant
zurück in der kanzlei in luzern die
eltern haben all die experten selber
gefunden und sie miteinander vernetzt
mario steht täglich in kontakt mit den
verschiedenen labors und vor allem dem
neurogenetik bürsten
es geht ihm alles viel zu langsam
also sich rasch mit zu sagen
dann machen wir vorwärts oder muss immer
auch liegen probiere die richtigen worte
finden oder wie so gut im auge es so
lang eigentlich nicht und wissenschaft
fördern müssen hier nicht im labor und
luke das tier zurück möchte wie lange
geht das
das dass das haar mir also ich geliebt
und ständig tauchen zusatzkosten auf die
die ganze kalkulation wieder über den
haufen werfen
finanziert dazu und was am laufen sei
untergegangen ist
ist der spitalaufenthalte posten
children's hospital selben boot aus dass
frau bereichert kann sein
vorschlag dass das 400 musikern gekostet
[Musik]
bei den finanzen gibt es aber auch gute
nachrichten
die ursprünglich anvisierte millionen
ist nach nur drei tagen beisammen
und somit
die griechischen zahlen sind das gerade
einer dieser großspender ist bei der
heutigen sammelaktion vor dem luzerner
fussballstadion dabei
auch andere firmen engagieren sich eine
luzerner bäckerei spendet 1000
schachteln pralinen die verkaufen sie
vor einem fußballspiel des fc luzern an
die besucher
maria schenkel ist fußball wichtig er
war schon immer fan des fcl
bei diesem spiel will er schweizweit auf
die sammelaktion aufmerksam machen
mit der fussball aktion steigt das
spenden total um weitere 50000 franken
an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
september 2009 10 morgen fliegen
schenkers nach boston abschied von den
nachbarn
wann valeria ihr medikament in boston
children's hospital zum ersten mal
bekommen wird ist aber immer noch unklar
[Musik]
auch valeria scheint zu spüren dass
etwas passiert in den letzten wochen
weint sie oft und lässt sich fast nicht
beruhigen
[Musik]
und größe des runden
zuversichtlich stimmt sie das war ja
kürzlich einen kleinen entwicklungsschub
hatte
[Musik]
valeria kann durchaus zeigen wenn sie
glücklich ist ihre augen strahlen und
sie zappelt mit den beinchen
das wunder passiert sie seien als ein
paar cent als wunder passieren wenn
mit helmut das hält so logisch
denn passiert es wundern das ist nach
wieder ganz normal muss
ein halbes jahr später inzwischen ist es
märz 2020 über die welt bricht das
corona virus herein in boston wartet
familie schenkel seit einem halben jahr
auf den beginn der behandlung
[Musik]
der pläne gott zum glück wieder in
bestform
da kann sie die ganze zeit und ruhe hat
und
sich zum glück ist
und da heute usa kurz was eigentlich
akku aber was hat sie mich belastet sich
das ja nicht so vorwärts kommt mit der
mit dem medikament für dich liebe
im februar feiert valeria ihren zweiten
geburtstag es könnte ihr letzter gewesen
sein
wenn durch durchschnitts salatic lulic
von den renten hätte valeria 23 grad
geklagt
aber egal
fokussiert
sich nicht einfach vom eindhoven
erreichten irgendwie eines
personalleiters eigenen infektion oder
bis dazu wo sie wird schwächeres
immunsystem wird schwächer
trotzdem läuft valeria die zeit davon
haben sie denn nie ans aufgeben gedacht
und glauben sie noch daran dass der
neurowissenschaftler wirklich ein
taugliches medikament entwickeln kann
und sie machen um das beste für
alles klar
bliebe also dass ich jetzt im moment
dadurch dragomir könnt ja und und als
familie
lichtblicke sind die besucher aus der
schweiz
maria und sein vater probieren
großvaters neue drohne aus
schenkels leben in einer kleinstadt in
der nähe des boston children's hospital
wie lange sie hier bleiben müssen wissen
sie nicht
doch wovon leben sie eigentlich
mario ist partner in der anwaltskanzlei
in luzern und kann von boston aus
arbeiten
die fangen reduziert geschafft da man
halte nun bevor was ich schon dass wir
als sparsame
ja mal gern mitgemacht oder grüner krise
wir sind einfach mit der familie hat die
therapie gegangen
und vielleicht später
und zustand mit kaltluft
endlich heute ist der große tag
nach einem jahr in boston bekommt das
medikament die zulassung der
arzneimittelbehörde fdp und valeria ihre
erste dosis valeria sehen so heißt das
medikament
es muss ihr in vollnarkose ins
rückenmark gespritzt werden damit es im
gehirn das fehlerhafte gehen abdecken
kann
parallel dazu werden valerie us
hirnströme überwacht der neuro genetiker
thema cdu der das medikament entwickelt
hat begleitet die behandlung auf schritt
und tritt beim ersten mal bekommt sie
nur eine ganz kleine dosis dann alle
zwei wochen etwas mehr sie scheint
valeria sehen gut zu vertragen die
veränderung ist offensichtlich
die inzwischen dreijährige reagiert
stärker auf ihre umwelt nimmt wahr was
um sie herum passiert hat deutlich
weniger krampfanfällen
sie blüht richtig auf trainiert ihre
muskeln
und eine weitere gute nachricht valeria
wird im sommer ein geschwisterchen
bekommen
trotz 24 stunden betreuung auch durch
die großeltern aus der schweiz
verschlechtert sich verlegers zustand
wieder
ein jahr nach beginn der behandlung
erreicht uns im september 2021 die
nachricht vor der sich alle gefürchtet
haben
valeria ist gestorben
[Musik]
und immer kopf das mit noch schnell sind
und dass mir das märchenhaus oder dass
das
weiß ich ja
und wenn alles gemacht damit das
möglichst schnell gegangen ist
deshalb kein schnellerer weg zum
medienhafen
unter ganz mag also die hoffnung die hat
man dir steht die sexy und die hoffnung
bis zum schluss sie die haben wir nie
verloren obwohl axel stein ist
was hat dann
schlussendlich zum tod wird von der
materie
setzt sich
jede flüssigkeit axa mit jeder mit ihrem
köpfe
über länge zieht man hätte das viel
sport entdeckt
ja das
mehr weiß nicht oder ich habe zudem nie
zeit spricht arzt weiß nieder das
muss der verkäufer
schockeffekt sie
vor dem oli co
aber
das ist nicht das das nicht sicher ist
mit einfach 2
winkler
die genaue todesursache wird noch
untersucht
dass es zu einer so dramatischen
entwicklung kam hat alle überrascht
auch den neurogenetik artemis eu
hätte erde nicht früher erkennen müssen
dass etwas nicht stimmt mit valeria
ist das ganze thema
involviert euro und der behandelnde arzt
dass rangnick und mit druck hätten
ja ziemlich g show erst die hauptsache
das signal gab
nachhinein
darf uns kein interview geben das spital
hat es ihm verboten heute treffen in
schenkels zu einem abschieds gespräch in
ein paar tagen fliegen sie zurück in die
schweiz ganz wird der kontakt aber nicht
abreißen
timothy hughes labor und andere
institutionen auch in europa werden
weiter an valeria sehen arbeiten denn
das medikament hat durchaus potenzial
im ersten halben jahr der behandlung
denen es valeria nämlich so gut dass sie
wie alle kinder an ihrem dritten
geburtstag in den lokalen kindergarten
kam die pre school hat eine klasse für
kinder mit speziellen bedürfnissen
schön dich zu sehen wie viele kinder
sind in einer klasse es sind zwölf
alle kinder ob gesund oder mit
beeinträchtigungen haben in boston
anrecht auf einen platz im kindergarten
so auch valeria am liebsten war sie auf
der schaukel wegen corona durften sie
die eltern aber nicht besuchen
foto anthony baffoe und so keine
teilhabe und dem ganzen umgehen wir
selbst gesetzt die es will
doch sehr emotional
also natürlich traurig aber
es ist gut es ist gut zu wissen ob sie
das noch
[Musik]
es ist schlimm ich vermisse die zeit
maria hat in der schaukel so gestrahlt
sie war glücklich ruhig und entspannt
im klassenzimmer zeigt ihnen lehrerin
michelle das lernspielzeug dass sie
extra für valeria zusammengestellt hat
glücklich zurück der schuh ist möchte
sich so wirklich stolz erbes selber
keine machen
gegangen ist haben wir natürlich hier
das sei ganz bestimmt und sind gespannt
diesen heil kommt und wenn du sie
irgendwie
ganz cool und
wunderschön
obwohl valeria nicht mehr lebt werden
maria und alexandra schenkel ihre
kontakte in boston weiter pflegen
ihre stiftung in die das gesammelte geld
fließt wird die weitere entwicklung des
medikaments mitfinanzieren
[Musik]
erhoffen sich und wir sehen
besser machen
respektiv sie
aufgelistet wie ihr das muss therapieren
wenn man valérie als zehn verabreicht
und für die hoffnung eigentlich immer
noch sehr groß dass auch in zukunft mit
diesem medikament besucht und das andere
kind geholfen
ihr letzter abschiedsbesuch vor dem
endgültigen rückflug in die schweiz
führt sie nach cape dort etwa eine
stunde außerhalb von boston
hier an der atlantikküste war auch einer
der lieblingsorte von valeria
[Musik]
sie hat ihn gefreut dass jetzt hat der
natur und an mir spazieren ja
man hätte idee dass er meistens
nachgegangen ist oder eine tagung
ausgegangen sind ja irgendwie
beziehungen
wichtig kostet sicher ist wir machen
weiter bis sich los und dann hat sie
ausprobiert
mitmachen ja gut ist gar nicht
[Musik]
bewusst dass sie am schluss schoss er
starke schmerzen
ich hoffe dass ich
sage das hat ihn oder sie
hätten wir die schlagen sie hat mir die
die schmerzen und
[Applaus]
und ich noch mal was wo sie hoffentlich
als sonst aber das
ist das wo es drauf steht eigentlich so
ein weiterer trost
kurz vor valeria steward ist harry zur
welt gekommen ihr kleiner kerngesunder
bruder
zeigen wollen sie ihn nicht ihr weiteres
leben soll privat sein ohne medien
witz des todes mit second vor dem ort wo
halten und zu tolerieren ganz wichtig
ist so muss man sie auch spitze zu
klettern
wir sind ganz froh
glücklich hunter tri und
festfreude ihm und er hilft dies auf den
strom kommt mit dem schwieriger
und co
[Musik]
[Applaus]